a long-anticipated face-to-face meeting
between the leaders of the world's two
most powerful Nations both aware of its
importance
we share responsibility in my view
to show that China and the United States
can manage our differences
prevent competition from becoming
anything every near conflict China's Xi
Jinping noted relations with the U.S
have just turned 50 and many believe
they're now at their lowest ever point
the current situation that the china-u.s
relationship is facing is a concern for
us all
the U.S and China have increasingly
disagreed on many fronts economic
diplomatic military as superpower Rivals
with flash points such as the
self-governing island of Taiwan and
access to technology threatening to turn
competition into confrontation this
meeting was aimed at setting out the
guard rails to ensure future relations
never escalate into hostilities he was
clear and I was queer they will defend
American interests and values promote
Universal human rights and stand up for
the international order and work and
lockstep with our allies and partners
we're going to compete vigorously but
I'm not looking for conflict
Biden also said she had agreed with him
that the threat of nuclear weapons being
used in Ukraine should be condemned
reaffirmed our shared belief in the
threat or the use of nuclear weapons is
totally unacceptable Biden came to Bali
emboldened by his midterm election
success reassuring many allies here of
continued U.S support with less chance
of a return to the America First policy
of the previous administration
for its part China remains deeply
suspicious of U.S intentions it believes
Washington is using concerns about human
rights and security to Rally a coalition
especially here in Asia Pacific to
constrain it from becoming a truly
Global superpower in the coming days
China and the U.S will be holding more
meetings with their G20 colleagues
pursuing agendas that may or may not
turn them more into superpower
adversaries Rob McBride Al Jazeera Bali